hi herzlich willkommen bei ZDF heute
live schön dass ihr dabei seid das Thema
des Tages ist die AFD besser gesagt ein
geplanter wahlkampfaftritt des AFD
Parteivorsitzenden Tino krupaller der
für ihn im Krankenhaus endete aber was
ist passiert lasst uns mal reinschauen
gestern später Nachmittag 16:30 Uhr der
Theaterplatz m im bayerischen
ingolstad wahkampfveranstaltung der AFD
gegen Demonstranten sind ebenfalls da
auftreten soll auch afdchef kupalla doch
er bemerkt plötzlich Schmerzen im
Oberarm ihm wird offenbar übel er muss
vor Ort medizinisch versorgt werden und
er kommt mit einem Rettungswagen in ein
Krankenhaus ja und die
Staatsanwaltschaft Ingolstadt ermittelt
jetzt wegen dieses Vorfalls den die AFD
als Angriff auf parteikochchef Tino
kopalla bezeichnet und auch Partei
Chefin Alice Weidel war zuletzt nicht
bei einer Parteiveranstaltung weil sie
laut AFD bedroht wurde über diese
Vorfälle darüber was wir wissen und was
wir vielleicht noch nicht wissen wollen
wir heute sprechen und zwar mit dem
Leiter des ZDF Landesstudios in München
in Bayern mit Stefan leifert und mit
hauptstadtkorrespondentin Nicole digmann
in Berlin und wie immer auch mit euch
wenn ihr Anmerkung Fragen zum Thema habt
dann schreibt uns gerne hier im Youtube
Chat oder per Mail an die jetzt
eingeblendete Adresse und über den
kupalla Vorfall spreche ich jetzt mit
Stefan leifert in München hallo Stefan
hallo aus München Stefan wie ist denn
die Lage aktuell in Ingolstadt ist Tino
krupaller noch im Krankenhaus Tino
krupaller scheint noch in Ingolstadt im
Krankenhaus zu sein wir haben dafür
allerdings nur eine Quelle nämlich die
AFD selbst das Büro von Tino kropaller
hat heute noch einmal bestätigt dass
Tino kropaller sich noch inärztlicher in
sogar intensivmedizinischer Behandlung
im Krankenhaus Ingolstadt befindet wir
haben mit der Polizei und auch dem
Krankenhaus in dem Timo kopalla liegen
soll versucht zu sprechen aber die
berufen sich auf die ärztliche
Schweigepflicht wollen das nicht
bestätigen also es gibt nur eine Quelle
dafür laut AFD ist Tino kopaller noch in
ärztlicher Behandlung in Ingolstadt im
Krankenhaus der Vorfall liegt ja jetzt
ungefähr 24 Stunden zurück noch immer
ist wahnsinnig viel unklar und offen
aber inzwischen trennt sich so ein
bisschen die spru vom Weizen und wir
können zumindest unterscheiden was wir
gesichert wissen und was nicht wir haben
die Bilder vom Beginn der Ver altung ja
gerade gesehen Timo kropaller fuhr also
in Ingolstadt auf dem Platz wo die
Veranstaltung stattfinden sollte vor es
hat dann eine begrüßungsszene gegeben er
hat Hände geschüttelt es wurden selfies
gemacht und dabei sei es wie das halt in
so einer Situation ist zu mehreren
Körperkontakten mit mehreren Personen
gekommen dann verging ein bisschen Zeit
und Tino kropaller wollte Richtung Bühne
gehen sich dorthin bewegen und dann
verspürte er Schmerzen im Oberarm mit
diesen Schmerzen ist er dann zu einem
Krankenwagen gegangen der der in der
Nähe stand hat sich dort behandeln
lassen und nach wenigen Minuten ist er
dann in ein Krankenhaus gebracht worden
dort wurde bestätigt gegenüber der
Polizei dass Tino kropalla dort mit
Schmerzen im Oberarm eingeliefert worden
sei man habe am Oberarm dann eine Rötung
schrästrich Schwellung festgestellt
weitere Untersuchung gemacht aber diese
Untersuchung haben Zitat dann keine
besonderen Auffälligkeiten mehr ergeben
es gab jetzt heute Nachmittag also von
noch nicht allzu langer Zeit eine
gemeinsame Erklärung von Polizei also
der Polizei in Ingolstadt und der
Staatsanwaltschaft und der entscheidende
Satz dort ist Zitat es liegen nach
jetzigen Zeitpunkt keinerlei
Erkenntnisse vor dass Herr krupaller
angegangen oder angegriffen worden ist
also das ist der Sachstand jetzt im
Moment die Polizei hat erste Zeugen
vernommen darunter natürlich kupala
selbst aber auch deren Personenschützer
sind befragt worden einige Ordner der
Veranstaltung und auch teilnehmende die
gestern auf der Veranstaltung waren und
jetzt laufen gerade zwei Gutachten eins
soll Aufschluss geben ob sich
irgendwelche Fremdkörper ein Gift ein
Mittel im Blut von Tino kopalla befindet
die Ergebnisse liegen noch nicht vor und
es gibt eine Untersuchung ob die
Kleidung von Tino kropaler irgendwie
Aufschluss darüber geben könnte dass das
ganze ein tätlicher Angriff war bisher
gibt es dafür aber laut Polizei noch
keinerlei
Anhaltspunkte ja die Staatsanwaltschaft
ingol Stadt ermittelt und du hast es
gerade schon angesprochen es gab ein
Statement und in das hören wir jetzt mal
rein die Staatsanwaltschaft Ingolstadt
hat ein Verfahren wegen Verdacht der
Körperverletzung eingeleitet gegen
Unbekannt das heißt dass wir im
Augenblick nicht gegen bestimmte
Beschuldigte ermitteln und es heißt aber
auch dass wir im Augenblick ermitteln ob
überhaupt ein Angriff stattgefunden hat
bei der Untersuchung wurde eine Rötung
am Oberarm festgestellt und eine kleine
Schwellung weitere Auffälligkeiten
konnten nach unseren derzeitigen
Informationen nicht festgestellt werden
auf der
Veranstaltung so wurden wurde uns von
Zeugen berichtet haben mehrere Personen
selfies mit Herrn krupalla
gefertigt sowohl Herr krupalla als auch
die Umständen Personen haben in ihren
Zeugen aussagen allerdings keine Angaben
gemacht darüber dass hier irgendwelche
auffälligen Handlungen stattgefunden
hätten also die Zeugen haben keine
keinen Angriff beobachtet haben keine
Handlungen in Richtung von Herrn kupalla
beobachtet die statsanwaltschaft
Ingolstadt wird zusammen mit der
Kriminalpolizei Ingolstadt weitere
Zeugen vernehmen es werden die und
Bildmaterial des Teilnehmer der
Veranstaltung zur Verfügung stellen wird
ausgewertet werden die Kleidung von
Herrn krupaller wurde an des
Landeskriminalamt gebracht die wird dort
untersucht werden auf mögliche
Auffälligkeiten und auch die Blutproben
die gestern genommen wurden im Klinikum
die werden analysiert
werden ja wir hören da es wird ermittelt
wegen Verdachts auf Körperverletzung
aber es gibt auch Ermittlung ob es
überhaupt ein Angriff gab das klingt
jetzt erstmal wie Widerspruch ab wann
ermittelt die Staatsanwaltschaft denn ja
dafür gibt's keine ganz klare Schwelle
die irgendwie definierbar wäre aber
sobald es Anhaltspunkte dafür gibt dass
es eine eine ein tätlicher Angriff
gewesen sein könnte dann wird ermittelt
dafür reichen aber z.B auch
Presseberichte es stand ja auch gestern
auf auf sehr schnell dann auf vielen
Online Portalen auf der Plattform x
wurde sehr schnell die Version auch
eines Angriffs verbreitet oder auch die
AFD selbst hat ja relativ schnell dann
eine Erklärung ab gegeben über den
Vorfall in olstadt und solche
Anhaltspunkte reichen dann schon für
Ermittlung mit der Tatsache dass jetzt
Ermittlung stattfinden ist noch nichts
darüber gesagt wie wahrscheinlich es ist
dass es einen Angriff gegeben hat es
wird einfach nur den Hinweisen die es
gegeben hat nachgegangen ob da etwas
dran sein
könnte ja wie geht denn die AFD jetzt
mit diesem Vorfall um du hast es gerade
schon kurz angerissen wir hören jetzt
noch mal in der Aussage die gab es
gestern unmittelbar nach dem
Vorfall uns bestätigt auf Tino Kalla
wurde hier an diesem Ort ein tätiger
Angriff getätigt so gehen diese Leute
mit unser politikerum das ist eine
Schande für Deutschland Merkel zöder und
konzorten haben das alles zu
verantworten liebe Freunde und wir
werden ihn am 18 einen den Denkzettel
verpassen dass sie sich so schnell nicht
mehr erholen
werden ja die AFD sprach also sehr
schnell von einem Angriff obwohl wir
haben es gerade gehört viele Fragen noch
offen sind wann können wir denn jetzt
mit Neuigkeiten der Behörden dazu
rechnen es laufen ja z.B verschiedene
Tests also heute sicherlich nicht mehr
es laufen jetzt Blutuntersuchung
verschiedene Gutachten unter anderem
auch das was die Kleidung betrifft wenn
es schnell geht dann wissen wir morgen
im Laufe des Tages mehr und können
vielleicht dann erste Anhaltspunkte
darüber
haben von den Behörden und auch vom
Krankenhaus selbst ob die
Blutuntersuchung jetzt irgendwie
Hinweise darauf geben dass es sich z.B
um einen Angriff mit einer Spritze
gehandelt
hat das wurde relativ schnell auch von
AFD nahen Medien selber verbreitet
angeblich sei eine eine Nadel die auf
eine Spritze hindeute am Tatort am
vermeintlichen Tatort gefunden die
Polizei bestätigt das nicht aber geht
aufgrund dieser Berichte jetzt wohl
diesem Verdacht nach und daher auch die
Blutuntersuchung wenn es schnell geht
wird es morgen es könnte aber auch noch
ein paar Tage länger
dauern ja danke Stefan und alles Gute
nach
München
ja nicht nur über Tino krupalla wird
gesprochen sondern auch über Partei
kchefin Alice Weidel die war zuletzt
nicht bei einer Kundgebung und laut AFD
das auch wegen eines Zitat
sicherheitsrelevanten Vorfalls und über
die Gründe dafür was wir wissen was wir
nicht wissen darüber spreche ich jetzt
mit hauptstadtkorrespondentin Nicole
Dickmann in Berlin hallo Nicole
hallo Nicole was wissen wir denn über
diese nicht wahrgenommene Kundgebung von
Alice Weidel
wir wissen dass Alice Weidel nicht da
war und wir wissen dass Alice Weidel
statt dort persönlich zu reden wie
eigentlich geplant sich in einer
Videobotschaft an die Leute dort
gewendet und gesagt hat sie wäre sehr
gerne da es sei aber leider nicht
möglich daraus wurde aus Teilen ihrer
Partei gemacht Alis Weidel sei aus
sicherheitsrelevanten Gründen dort nicht
erschienen sie befinde sich seit 10
Tagen in einem safeehus an einem
geheimen Ort weil es einen Angriff einen
geplanten Angriff auf sie gegeben habe
vor dem man sie jetzt schützen
müsse ja und zu diesem wie Alice Weidel
sagt geplanten Angriff was weiß man denn
zu dem oder was weiß man dazu auch nicht
also wir wissen mittlerweile aus weidels
Umfeld das ist jetzt gesichert dass
Weidel und ihre Familie an ihrem Wohnort
in der Schweiz am 23 September das war
vor letzten Samstag aus ihrer Wohnung
quasi evakuiert worden und an einen
sicheren Ort gebracht worden sind weil
es angeblich eine Bedrohungslage gegeben
haben soll dort ist die Familie eine
Nacht geblieben an diesem sicheren Ort
aber schon am Montag also am 25
September war Alice Weidel hier in
Berlin ich selber habe sie dann auch am
6 September gesehen das war ein Dienstag
es war Sitzungswoche im Bundestag und am
Dienstag verst leiten die Fraktionen vor
ihren
fraktionsitzungen
traditionell kurze Pressekonferenzen und
das hat unter anderem Alis Weidel
zusammen mit Tino krupalla an diesem
Dienstag auch getan sie war die ganze
Woche über hier in Berlin und Wald nun
seit mehreren Tagen auf Mallorca im
Urlaub dort war sie eben auch am 3
Oktober statt auf der
Wahlkampfveranstaltung auf der sie
eigentlich sein sollte und wo sie dann
eben nur per Videobotschaft vertreten
war
ja und auch zu diesem Sachverhalt hat
sich die AFD dann recht schnell
Verhalten und dazu haben wir
Bilder Alice Weidel wurde derart bedroht
mit ihrer Familie dass sie nicht nur
nicht hierherkmen konnte sie wurde von
zu Hause evakuiert in ein Safe houseus
gebracht und kann das Haus nicht
verlassen Hausarrest für einen politisch
lieigen Kandidaten das gab es zuletzt
vor der Teilung und die Leute in der DDR
die sind nicht auf die Straße gegangen
die haben nicht für Freiheit gekämpft
damit über 30 Jahre später ein Schöder
und ein Olaf Scholz eine Politik machen
dass die Partei und Fraktionsvorsitzende
einer wirklichen Oppositionspartei ihres
Lebens nicht mehr
sicher ja hier wird also gesprochen von
einem mehrtägigen aufhalt in einem
safeehus das deckt sich ja aber nicht
mit der Timeline die du uns gerade
geschildert hast oder nein das deckt
sich auch nicht mit den Aussagen von
Alice weesprecher selbst W wir da gerade
gehört haben das war Norbert
Kleinwächter das ist nicht niemand das
ist ein wichtiger Funktionär in der AFD
der ist stellvertretender
Fraktionsvorsitzender im Bundestag und
was Norbert Kleinwächter dort gerade
erzählt hat ist schlichtweg falsch Alis
Weidel war nicht mal zwei Tage an einem
sicheren Ort wie wir jetzt gehört haben
handelte es sich dabei auch nicht um ein
safeaus sondern um ein Hotel und von
Hausarrest kann nun wirklich überhaupt
gar keine Rede sein denn Alice Weidel
war erst in Berlin hier zur
Sitzungswoche und anschließend ist sie
in Urlaub nach Mallorca geflogen wie
gesagt das hat auch ihr Sprecher
mittlerweile bestätigt sie ist dort auch
noch so viel also zur Faktenlage ich
gucke gerade mal in den Chat und es gibt
noch einige Fragen hier fragt z.B jemand
ich gehe noch mal kurz zum falkalla den
da kannst du ja auch was zu sagen da
gibt's auf jeden Fall eine Menge Fragen
hier schreibt jemand auf Youtube
angeblich wurde doch eine Spritze
gefunden wo ist die denn ja das fragen
sich viele Leute wir haben es eben von
Stefan leifert gehört unserem
Studioleiter in München diese Spritze
ist in den Medien aufgetaucht allerdings
wird es bisher stand jetzt von der
Polizei nicht bestätigt dass es diese
Spritze gibt wir wissen es also
schlichtweg nicht mhm was auch so ein
bisschen durchs Internet gegeistert ist
ist ein Bild bzw Bilder nach den die
User hier auch Fragen auf YouTube wird
gefragt im Internet kursieren Bilder von
zwei vermeintlich Tatverdächtigen können
Sie dazu was sagen ja es gibt keine
Tatverdächtigen wir haben ja eben
schon die Sprecherin der
Staatsanwaltschaft Ingolstadt gesehen
die ja relativ breit ausgeführt hat wie
gerade stand der Ermittlungen ist und
sie hat uns auch gesagt im Interview es
gibt viele Zeugen die befragt worden
sind es gibt Zeugen die noch befragt
werden sollen aber es gibt keine
Tatverdächtigen und hier fragt noch
jemand gibt es Videoaufnahmen ist denn
bekannt ob jemand den Vorfall vielleicht
mit dem Handy aufgenommen hat auch da
sind die Ermittlungsbehörden gerade dran
also Polizei und Staatsanwaltschaft
Ingolstadt es wird gerade alles
gesammelt was auf dem Markt ist man kann
sich ja vorstellen gerade bei so einer
Wahlkampfveranstaltung jeder hat sein
Handy dabei und versucht zu filmen da
wird jetzt eben gerade danach gefragt
möglichst alles was an Material
vorhanden ist auf den Handys eben von äh
Gästen von Zuschauern an die
Strafermittlungsbehörden
ähm zu übergeben s dass man dieses
Material auswerten kann auf der Suche
nach möglichen Tätern auf der Suche nach
der Antwort auf die Frage hat es einen
tätlichen Vorfall wie die AFD es ja
behauptet überhaupt gegeben und wenn ja
wer steckt dahinter ja und und
abschließend noch eine Frage die hier
mehrere im Chat stellen wie gesagt wir
wissen zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt wenig bzw
es sind sehr viele Fragen die ihr hier
auch gerade stellt noch offen fragt
jemand auf Youtube drohen der AFD
rechtliche Konsequenzen wenn der Angriff
gelogen ist ja also das kann passieren
wobei ich nicht weiß was Tino kopalla
selber gesagt hat ich habe mich ja eben
auf seinen Sprecher bezogen Stefan
leifert hat sich auf seinen Sprecher
bezogen da muss man dann also auch ganz
klar auseinanderk müsern wer hat mit der
Polizei gesprochen und im Zweifel eine
Falschaussage gemacht auch gegenüber der
Staatsanwaltschaft Nicole danke dass du
bei uns warst uns von den Fakten
berichtet hast uns eingeordnet hast was
wir wissen und was wir auch noch nicht
wissen alles Gute nach Berlin danke sehr
gerne ja ihr merkt ähm hier ist ganz
viel noch unklar wir hoffen dass wir mit
dieser Sendung ein bisschen Licht ins
Dunkel bringen konnten danke schön für
eure Fragen und eure anmerk und bis zum
nächsten Mal bei ZF heute
live